okay next game Rainmaker again we had we
got those pretty dry scotch game last
time maybe he go for something else now
the office they like this kind of
position yeah well I always tell myself
I should look look for something more
exciting here but oh what this MN I just
I just made a yeah finger of failure we
say in German of course I need to
recapture with the Queen this is just
just terrible ah ok how do i how do I
keep some cool wow this is looking
really terrible how do I keep a play in
the position here
pool
what this is really bad okay maybe queen
poor maybe what about rook before rugby
for F for something like this okay
didn't take this into account should
have maybe make the rook look really
stupid and before
what about deform looks doesn't look
nice I know yeah this this would prevent
the night from going to III but also
give him be four as an attacking square
this one is hanging but ok but should be
seven but this is really terribly bad
name Kent
get just a great great try to hate to do
to avoid this dry position by piper
capture with the body oh my yeah look f
3 to 2 g-3 now ya need to cover h6
you know why it just has some an attack
for free yeah let's say rook check 94
and so on yeah or this one we should be
seven maybe
Chuck
yeah this is just lost um yeah
yeah it's black resign okay what yeah of
course I I just I just made this vibe by
an accident I'm any to play Queen f6 and
we got the same dry end game that we
hadn't game before this is just terrible
copia next came